Boo hey
What's wrong with Baru s go
It's smart because the number of pies has increased so much.
It's sly
to keep it secret, isn't it? It's secretly hidden behind me, isn't it?
Maybe you have a bad drinking habit
, please don't be stupid 3. Subaru-kun Subarukan Don't call me Subaru three times as
much as usual. Edo is always an important job, so I'm careful.
Although it's gone
, it's a strong image that the spirit of Zumaru-kun is
rattling and the hands that aren't made by the maker are my knowledge, but it
's true that the two pairs are tribal and strong against alcohol since I was
little.  Nam also often drank and compared with adults. He
confessed his impression of his youth as a matter of course. In
fact, Lamb's complexion and Ruri are suspicious, and he has a cow pattern
.
But the house and the harvest
are the chest cavity that girls shouldn't drink alcohol
[Music]
That's an extreme story
Nah Bear
[Music]
Which one comes from eating music, but
Emilia Burn  But I don't keep it too. I
understand.
[Music]
Photograph Danum should be burned on the eyelids.